I'm Melissa Odin I'm the founder and CEO
of the abortion survivors Network
we are a healing and advocacy
organization that serves abortion
survivors so the babies who survive
failed abortions we serve survivors
around the world and their families
including their moms who are impacted
after an abortion fails and of course I
have my own backstory that led me to
creating this organization I myself am
an abortion Survivor in 1977 I survived
a saline infusion abortion that was
forced upon my birth mother by her
family I soaked in a toxic salt solution
for five days being poisoned and scalded
to what was intended to be my death and
on the fifth day of the abortion
procedure I was accidentally born alive
you know sadly there were demands made
to lead me to die at St Luke's Hospital
in Sioux City Iowa by my own grandmother
who was a nurse at that facility and
gratefully uh after a few minutes I know
that I was ultimately rushed off to the
NICU by a brave nurse who was willing to
do the right thing for me and for me
that's what the born alive vote is all
about is ensuring that babies like me
are provided Medical Care my life no
survivor's life should ever be left in
the hands of whoever is working that day
the short version of the bill would be
that it would
start the process where we would have
reporting of the incidence of failed
abortions and abortion survivors there
is no federal reporting that happens and
obviously we need to know just how big
of a problem this is in order to meet
the needs of survivors and women and
also medical providers that are impacted
by this so we're looking at reporting
we're looking at ensuring that babies
are provided Medical Care and not being
left to die people can look through CDC
reports and know that babies can survive
minutes hours days after failed
abortions without medical care
this should not ever be a question
uh it also would ensure that women who
experience a failed abortion could have
could take a stand right could sue the
abortionist if they don't provide their
child Medical Care knowing that it was
blocked over 80 times when we had
speaker Pelosi obviously yesterday was
very historic which is why it is
essential that this body the United
States House of Representatives condemns
these heinous acts of political violence
I am proud to be an original co-sponsor
of this legislation and will always and
forever stand on the right side of
history when it comes to protecting The
Unborn certainly it's so emotional to be
in that gallery and see the vote
happening
there were Democrats dressed all in
white making their stand that they of
course were standing in opposition to
the bill and it's almost Indescribable
for me to say what that's like to see
the people who are in opposition of
truly who I am and what I have suffered
and and the population that I serve what
they're suffering still today expecting
parents have enough worries they should
not have to worry about extreme
politicians in their doctor's office or
Hospital
thinking they somehow know better I urge
my colleagues to vote no on H.R 26. it
is a bit unnerving to see that but I've
been doing this for so long that it
doesn't surprise me but I I'm so so
emotional every time I see our leaders
our Republican leaders taking that stand
the messaging that has come out in the
last week is that the Republicans are
clearly taking a stand and sending a
message uh that that they're trying to
restrict abortion and for me what I look
upon what has happened I look at that
and say they are taking a stand in
defense of life and not just for
children like beef but for women like my
biological mother who deserved better
than to have an abortion forced upon her
but the same arguments we've heard for a
decade are the same arguments I heard
yesterday and I've seen it even today in
the media and none of it surprises me
but it's everything from this doesn't
happen well are they asking any of us
who have lived to tell this story what
our experiences are they asking these
moms are they looking at data the way
that we do what about all of these
instances and what about all of the
reports in the handful of States who
actually do report out their statistics
why is it that in States like Minnesota
and Texas when they identified babies
are surviving abortions you read in
those reports that those children were
not provided in medical care tell me
there isn't a problem
put themselves in the shoes of someone
like me who not only suffered trauma in
the womb but has suffered trauma
throughout my life as a result of it not
just emotional but physically the way
that abortion has affected my body I may
not be missing limbs but I can tell you
my body has been impacted by that
abortion ending my life
is not the solution to that problem
ensuring that that never happened in the
first place is what should have happened
and so I want people to really kind of
take a step back from all of the fight
that happens in social media in
particular and be willing to listen to
stories right be open-minded to the
other side of things and contact us ask
some ask some questions I would be more
than willing to have a conversation with
someone but there is more to the story
than what we have lived with for the
last 50 years under row